well thanks for the intro no and I have
been talking about having this talk for
about six months or so I was looking
forward to doing it in Berlin but
unfortunately that's not going to happen
so I'm doing it from a very hot bedroom
in London and today I'll give really a
brief introduction to my personality in
Python and yeah as mentioned I'm a
little constrained in time so anything
that I don't get to then please feel
free to ping me on Twitter or LinkedIn
you know and so on
I'm happy to take questions offline
because we don't have time again so
let's just jump into it a little bit
about me I'm asking a data scientist and
data science leader until recently and
others in fact I've mentioned I'm
london-based originated from Tel Aviv on
a personal note I haven't had a haircut
in four months due to qivana
and sometimes like tweet interesting
things on twitter so feel free to follow
me at hello neo so today as I mentioned
a quick introduction to network analysis
we are constrained in time network
analysis is a huge topic and you can
find on youtube workshops from pythons
and PI data conferences we reach for
like three or four hours at lens just to
introduce people to network analysis and
obviously we have 25 minutes or so so we
are really going to touch the bare-bones
I'm not talking LC so my agenda for
today my objectives are very very simple
I want to show you that networks and now
network analysis is extremely useful and
I also want to show you that it's really
easy to get started yeah so our plan is
simple we'll discuss why should you
should learn about network analysis and
a few motivating examples will give the
very brief bail bonds in theoretical
intro will analyze real data with Python
so you can see that it's very easy to
get started and time permitting we'll
explore more
useful and interesting examples from
real life what we won't do in the
interest of time is to yeah dive deep
into the theory and everything that
there is to learn because there is a lot
to learn and it's really fascinating
again for simplicity is there will be no
mask no matrix of presentation and no
Greek letters whatsoever
we won't dive deep into the theory
behind the different things that we'll
see I think what's important to know
about network analysis or what's cool
about it is that sometimes the result we
get are intuitive for a human for the
human brain but there are very complex
if you want to devise an algorithm to do
it in an inefficient way and finally and
most importantly we are not going to use
the seawall today
it's tempting when you have a network
analysis talk to discuss about you know
how virus is spread and everything like
that but I feel like the world has had
enough of that in the last two or three
months and I think that the last thing
you want to do is to hear about it some
more from me so we will not use that for
today yeah
so next quick kind of like intros to why
and what you can do with that work
analysis first of all I think that is
data scientists we come from various
backgrounds myself I come from economics
I have people in my team that are
structural engineers and chemists and
biologists and a few physicists and
physicists that's you know that his
specialty is in lasers which is
extremely cool but you know doesn't have
anything to do with data science and
networking us is just one of those
things that it's extremely useful but
people don't really learn about it when
they transition into the other side so I
think it's something that that's kind of
a secret weapon but it shouldn't really
be a secret weapon furthermore I think
that humans as humans we tend to think
linearly owing like tabular form but
then if you add network analysis on to
there's like all the network
representation of data then you get like
you kind of
lock and you they mentioned well you can
really learn a lot more from the data
sets that you have
and finally it's just cool so let's
let's let's be concretely let's talk
about actual problems that you may use
to use network analysis to solve and
these are actual problems and you can
get paid to answer these problems and I
know that because I was paid to answer
these problems with network analysis so
let's assume that your product data
scientist for peer-to-peer payments app
I'm not sure if there is something that
in Berlin in the US as a big service
called then go on by PayPal basically
you know I can I can then move you some
money you can vend my it's back in in
the UK we have monster which is again
the same the same basic idea and think
about like whatsapp only instead of
sending messages he sent he sent you
some summary and then you are the
scientist and then a few people around
the business ask you several questions
the customer service team could ask you
who's we we have a bunch of customers
calling us or saying a support request
who's and whose call should we answer
first who should we get give white blood
treatment to and who can we be
prioritizing the list which is a very
concrete and good question the marketing
team could tell you hey we've got some
money for you know for influencers
campaign can you tell me who the
influences are so we could spend them
that budget efficiently the product team
could ask you hey who's our well power
users what do we want to kind of keep in
mind when we design a new feature for
example and the customer research team
again should ask you questions like hey
who do we want to interview in the next
time we do any customer testing so
actual real questions and of course
there are many other use cases in real
life everything pretty much everything
could be models a network so of course
in real life then a lot of research and
a lot of info about how you can use your
net funding a job is actually network
analysis problem finding a spouse
anything on Google really is
one giant network of data how you you
know you can use network analysis to
detect bots or troll networks on Twitter
you can detect people on reddit Seth
kind of cheating with karma with the
upload system if there is a financial
crisis like in the 2008 for the
financial crisis the Obama
administration to the best of my
knowledge used network analysis to
decide which banks to bail out and which
banks not to you have personal
personalized recommendations which is
which is a huge use case for network
analysis it's pretty kind of pretty
intuitive you know if if you like a
certain movie for example and certain
film and then many people like you know
could like that film also like these
other films and we can recommend you
know another film for you and pretty
accurately and most importantly this is
an example I always go back to voting in
the Eurovision can be modeled which
network analysis and a husband model
analysis and given the time you'll
actually see it live in action in a very
very interesting website so what is it
you can go to Wikipedia and read this
incredibly interesting description which
is not very useful friendly in one
common very very common sense of the
term and graph is an ordered ve
comprising so it's not very user
friendly and guess what it's even less
user friendly when it's in German
because I don't picture so if we want to
keep it simple we can think of networks
as just points and lines if you can draw
a conceptual relationship between any
two things it's likely that you can
model them at a network so just a few
examples
you know people obviously are an example
of a network because we have friendships
before each other and so on communicate
is one another companies try this way
another you can think even enough like
bus stops as networks points on a
network and then buses said go for one
stop to another from that network
similarly a bicycle sharing scheme
trees as we mentioned they exchange your
vision points and even Wikipedia
articles pretty much any time I open
Wikipedia I find myself kind of opening
Wikipedia just to read this one article
but then I find myself clicking on a
bunch of links and opening more and more
tabs to eat other things so different
different articles on Wikipedia could be
models of network and when they are
connected for one article to another so
that's essentially a network which is
pretty cool and they're all sort of like
interesting exercise of media about you
know like if you if you're looking for a
homework assignment from this from this
lecturer is like trying to figure out
you know how many steps does it take to
get from point A to point B on Wikipedia
from an article about Abraham Lincoln to
an article about tick tock right so
there are obvious examples that we'll
use today just insure ourselves to the
concepts of a network in Facebook which
is something that we all know news so we
have this blondie guy and he there's
another blonde person and they are
connected on Facebook right so that was
out the points and lines and then
obviously if every one of them knows
more people and there are more
relationship which means those people
and that's a very very simple basic
network that'd be just great
that's so far it's pretty
straightforward
so apparently as it turns out those
points and lines actually have real
names in computer science the points are
called nodes and the lines are called
edges or links in math its vertices and
edges or arcs in physics it's sites and
barns and in sociology it's actors which
is cool and ties or relations and a lot
of the work around that walk analysis
actually comes from social network
analysis there's a very famous paper by
Mark littell which about yes
exactly about the strength of weak ties
it's been cited more than 56 thousand
times so it's a pretty popular they will
be using nodes and edges because that's
just what I'm used to very very high
level the main types of networks are
directed them I'm directed undirected
are like friendships and Facebook's
doing if I'm not friend on Facebook
noise also my friend that's under and
then the things like Twitter for example
snapchat or Instagram or tic toc where
you know if I followed know as dick
talks and it doesn't necessarily mean
that nawfal is mine and so on there are
other things like multigraphs and multi
directed graphs but in the interest of
time and confusion to what yet so
Facebook if you go back to our Facebook
and example Facebook in undirected graph
and again applying our new terminologies
and these are the notes in blue and
these are the edges in teal and this
point I'd like to add just one more
concept into the mix and we'll see that
with these three things
nodes edges and pass which is the next
thing that I'm going to introduce we can
do some pretty cool stuff
static analysis so paths are just a
collection of edges from one point to
another point from one node to another
another node on the graph as long as
there is no repetition so any any root
any walk from one node to another as
long as there's no repetition in edges
or nodes that's a path so this is one
path in purple this is a different path
and get another one so quick recap notes
edges best so far I think so good right
I hope that's not cool no no okay so
this is PI data so let's do it in Python
Network X an amazing library that is
very comprehensive
it's it has a very friendly you API and
documentation and it's like if you need
to get started network analysis do it
with
okay X because this is the most robust
and friendly library there is out there
it doesn't scale immensely grateful like
very very big graphs you can do you know
in with other tools and the
visualization for lot of graphs earrings
really good data and there are other
tools you can use like Steffi Graf's
tool I grass and guess tree which is not
actually Python so the data set will
explode today comes from venmo
which is the service I mentioned earlier
I'm gonna try to open a link rely in
real time and hopefully it will actually
walk okay this is venmo okay as i
mentioned then will allows you one
person to send another person money on
an app and the interesting thing about
venmo is that those transactions are
actually public so you can you know you
can pick an api your if you for instance
look for long enough in that commerce of
the internet you will find you're likely
going to find a large data set that you
could analyze so i'm gonna work some
magic and i'm gonna try to do a bunch of
stuff for the same time let's try to mmm
go one step let's stop the script here
real quick so you could see that in real
time things happen
okay translate yeah it's not gonna
happen
there you go alright so in real time
this is actually when venimos website
right now and i just stopped the script
form update from updating it but you can
see transactions you can see connections
that have happened on vendo so you can
see a person named sky eff paid janji a
certain amount of money for future
coffee date which is great you can see
the julia is paid Pluto s to help with
your bills this month and so on these
are actual transactions that just happen
and then
and what we can do we can analyze that
so so let's hop back for the deck to the
deck for just a second and actually
let's go to the jupiter notebook I'm
sorry I'm still trying to figure out how
to interact with zoom and not have my
computer crash at the same time
hopefully the font is large enough in
the notebook so this is a snapshot I
took from awhile ago from venmo
you can see if you look really squint
really hard to say that Leona paid John
and hunter paid Bryan and Eric are paid
Monica and this is very very easily
represented here as you know nodes and
edges and let's let's actually do that
in pure Python oh and Python lists
Network X so let's along actually the
code font is a bit smaller
really okay okay it's gonna be a little
challenging but I'm sure we can make it
go okay that's fine okay okay this is
like super blind okay cool so just
import network and network X as an X
because that's the convention and then a
bunch of other stuff like panda is a
metal plate and collections and so on so
in order to create your first network
with Network X here's what you need to
do you need to assign G to be annex that
graph or call the graph method from
Network X and you created a network
congratulations and it will Tex anything
really could be reserved as nodes it
doesn't have to be for instance just an
integer it could be a bunch of stuff and
now let's populate the graph okay that
we just created and we will pass in
order to to populate the graph you
created with this data here we'll just
pass it as the list of tuples
so as we saw earlier leonard senpai john
hunter paid brian and erica paid Monica
whereas we'll use the N edges from
method Bank done and if you don't you
don't have to believe me let's let's
just you know visualize it so there is a
very useful control network X method
really I mean basically you pass G which
is the network and then a bunch of other
parameters just to make it look nicer
but you know you don't need to spend too
much time thinking about it and you can
see this is exactly what we saw up there
only this is from a network we just
created use network X so BAM with it
like two minutes we created our first
network which is nice but it's not super
exciting because it's a stupid small
network with you know six actors and
three edges so let's do it in kind of a
larger scale again as I mentioned if you
look long enough on the internet you
will find data sets for venmo
and what we'll do is use a larger data
set which is a very large graph and then
this is a plan we'll start from the
large data set we'll break it down to
smaller sub graphs will zoom into one of
the seraphs and in that one will
discover communities and we'll discuss
what communities meaning in a little bit
and then after we find their communities
will actually look at interesting
individuals in those communities sounds
good
thank you no cool so let's load a bigger
data set we'll do it with pandas and
here you go so this is there are six six
hundred thousand records and basically
we have send an ID and receiver idea
stability is the person who sent money
and receive IDs ID for the person who
received money at this point I should
say that all the data you'll see today
has been obfuscated so in anonymize so
you know there's nothing here that
that will be identifiable for the people
who were actually in Deutsch and data
set but the structure of the network is
preserved because I just obfuscated the
actual IDs and other Vega so at this
point what you can do is you can use a
front pendants edge list method to
populate a network with you know view
data frame you just pass the data frame
you define what the source is who sent
to whom what the target is what the
target is who received the money or you
know in any other case that you may have
and then you will create actually a
digraph which is a directed graph what I
mentioned earlier which makes sense in
the minimal case because the fact that I
send nor money does not necessarily
unfortunately means that she sends it
back to me and I'm sorry I know if I'm
using you too much as an example because
you are the only thing from the zoom
from zoom I can see right now so
unfortunately for you I'll have to go
back to you quite a bit yeah let's run
that it will take a little bit of time
fingers crossed
fingers crossed
there you go okay so we have we
mentioned that we have six hundred
thirty seven thousand records so none of
the transfers but those transfers occur
between about seven hundred and ten
thousand different individuals okay and
we see that there are also zero isolates
so these are nodes that don't receive
anything we don't send anything which
makes sense that we don't have them in
our data set because other why would
there be if we have a transaction
deficit cool so if we wanted to
visualize that flower network and
remember what I told you about network
acts are having shortcomings in the
visualization of large networks
Department this is what will get the red
dots are the nodes and black lines are
the edges so I don't know what about you
but for me this is not very useful so
what what can we do so we can use other
you know we can visualize it with other
tools and figure out a way to do it oh
we can for the sake of this presentation
we can kind of zoom in on one subgroup
we think that Network and kind of
visualize that if it will be like and
smaller and more user-friendly and like
yeah let's let's go with that because
I'm more concerned with like an
intuitive understanding of like a
small-scale network rather than trying
to really make sense of a huge huge
graph
cool so let's find those sub sub sub
groups or sub graphs inside this big
giant gratitude created those things are
known as connected components and
connected components basically subsets
of the original nodes that follow two
rules
first of all there is a path which is
the wall that we learned earlier between
any two nodes in the subset and there is
no path to any other node elsewhere so
in a very basic Facebook example we saw
earlier this is actually this is the
entire graph and it's also a connected
component because if you wanted to reach
one note from another node there is a
path you can find a path so this is one
big connected component however if I
came with a big pair of scissors and I
severed the connection here between
blondie and blondie then I would get two
connected components okay because here
is one connected component because I can
get here I can get from you know one
node to another there is a pattern here
I can get from any one node to another
there is a path but there is nothing in
between I can't get there is no path to
another node so these are self-contained
and diesels and self-contained and in
network's terminology this is called a
connected component as you can imagine
there is a built-in method to do that a
network acts I don't need to run fur
because it's a stupid example we will
use something it's called a weakly
connected component I'm not going to get
into the intricacies right now I don't
want to confuse people too much but
trust me it's for the sake of argument
so weakly connect component we are going
to run that for a bit it's a little it's
a little intensive and we'll see that
we're generating some stats and we see
from you know that large network of 707
interactions we created we found a bunch
of connected components and the biggest
connected component inside that network
has eighteen thousand six hundred and
thirty members which is pretty cool
because think of if you think about it
you know it's likely that many people of
those eighteen thousand six hundred
thirty don't know a child but there is a
path so if they really wanted to
transfer money for just you know if they
found a person random person on the
street was you know in that
eighteen eighteen thousand six hundred
and thirty they could find a path which
fairly cool and it's also fairly cool
that we could find this huge community
locally inside the bigger the bigger
graph and if you kind of plot the top
five will see that you know the second
biggest one is eighteen hundred strong
and so on it could goes down pretty
rapid now as a presenter of a zoom talk
I have the benefit of cherry-picking the
data points I wanted to handle so I'll
do just that these this is one connected
component that I cherry-pick from the
data and I'll use that these are all
user IDs and I'll use them to create a
sub graph a sub graph is basically a
subset of the original notes and network
X knows how to handle that so if you
take if will define G sub which is G sub
graph and we just take the original
graph G the big one of seven hundred
thousand and we use the sub graph method
and we specify which nodes network X
knows to take those nodes and all of the
connection of the graph structure
between them and which is very useful so
we see that our fourteen hours or
seventy eight connections between them
which is much more manageable and
actually when I try to visualize that
again with the same draw method but
given that I zoomed in like twenty
percent I'm not sure what we're going to
actually see okay it's manageable it's
manageable it's not too bad now this is
even though it doesn't fit the entire
screen I think maybe if I do this it
will here you can see that it's much
much more user-friendly and much more
interesting than the other thing that we
saw earlier okay so cool I'm going to
jump back and forth let's add user IDs
just so you know we can can see that
it's easy to do so we just have need to
add with labels keyword eventually to
I didn't appreciate how much zoom slows
Danny computer okay so we added user ID
is great it's not very you know useful
so let's end the the names
I'm gonna read another data data that a
frame that has the you know plots that
connects user IDs to first name and
gender for example doesn't really matter
are the point I'm trying to make you
that you can also in addition to the
nodes and address you can also apply
attributes to-220 graph and
[Music]
that's useful if you want to do
something a little bit more complicated
so I added the names you're probably not
going to see them very clearly that's
fine you'll see you will make it better
in a sec let's let's just take a quick
break and kind of see where we are so we
started from a large network which
wasn't manageable and inside our
notebook for today then we decided to
zoom in on one side graph sub graph
which is all these nice people now what
we're going to do next is when we're
going to detect communities and we're
going to zoom in on individuals so what
do I mean by communities this hopefully
you'll see it clear now this structure
is interesting and intuitively if we
cannot have to eyeball it we would say
that we can detect communities ourselves
all of these people over here seem like
a community of their own and these
people look like a tight-knit community
and these people and these people these
people are all kind of separate
communities so if we had to avoid you
know that kind of make sense but how do
we do it despite them let's head back
it's a little complicated again as I
mentioned some of the algorithms to
actually do something in Python are
quite quite sophisticated
I'll say that intuitively the way to
think about communities is that you know
you have your own group of friends some
other person you know has their own
group of friends and you don't know that
person's friends and your friends don't
know that person's friends but I am
aware that there is another person that
I kind of know that has known his own
friends so unlike connected components
which you know were completely separate
entities when you look at communities
and there are basically track knit
groups but a weakly connected to one
another that there is some knowledge of
one another but they don't really hang
out I hope that makes sense
we will actually do it the way we will
actually detect communities in our
subgraph is by cheating we want you
something building in networks we'll use
a library called Python move on after
after the algorithm yeah we ran it we
found found them it's fairly very
straightforward and then what I'm doing
here is I'm actually going to plot the
same network we saw earlier but I use
the data that we found in the
communities and then every communities
that are just detected will get a
different color so let's let's see what
I mean there you go hope you can see it
again it's a little bit of a problem
problem here when I had to zoom in but
if you really squint very very hard
you'll see that all these people that we
saw earlier that we said hey this kind
of local community well they are very
yellow they got they got say one color
the yellow alone and all of these people
there's a question on YouTube which
might be interesting right now that
person would like to know if we can
determine the width of the edges by some
metric I'm not exactly sure what this
person means does it make sense to you
it does make sense to me I'll come back
to it in the end it's a perfectly think
it's a great question and I kind of kind
of mentioned it before in the deck I
said there's also like multi graphs and
stuff so both are graphs basically kind
of refer to you know when the
relationship between notes could have
multiple edges so for instance I can
send more money on than most several
times and then you can you can kind of
look at the number of times I sent no
money or their mouths and kind of
determined that our relationship may be
stronger and kind of kind of give a
weight to the edge which will be
proportional to their you know either
the number of times I sent how many or
the total some stuff like that but I'm
really trying to keep things simple it's
it's it
question it's the next step definitely
but I'm really doing the bare bones here
to try to keep the conversation going
and I do have a hard stop soon so I'm
just trying to power slew the
information that's alright okay thanks
cool so just to recap as we said earlier
we're kind of seeing that the delgo
managed to detect what we watch what we
saw by eyeballing the data that these is
the community by itself and these people
are community and these people are
community what we managed to kind of see
intuitively so did the algorithm and now
is the question here's a question for
you who are like the important notes in
that this network and again by polling
it you can kind of say there's a few
interesting individuals here that kind
of get a lot of you know they're in the
center and then they get a lot of arrows
that come in in that they have a lot of
edges let's do it in kind of network
analysis speak so there are a lot of
ways to score rank nodes there and there
is no one right way depends on like the
context and the goal there is one of
them basic and most naive ones is called
like the gree centrality and you can
also think about is like in and outs
degree centrality which goes back to
what that person from YouTube just asked
so basically you know if I have a lot of
nodes of a lot of people sending me
money then maybe I'm more important than
someone who just have you know one
transaction of them oh that's a very
naive way to look at it and there are a
few things that are a little bit more
complex like between the centrality
which we'll see in a bit or PageRank
PageRank is the algorithm that was
developed by Larry Page and Sergey Brin
and you know how they ranked each th web
site on the internet and kind of managed
to kind of plot them on the network and
figure out who's which website is more
interesting than another and then they
built a small company called Google and
the rest is history
between centrality which is one of the
metrics we will use just now is very
interesting so just kind of to be an
intuitive sense of it if we talked about
pass earlier we can think that you know
it whenever we want to guess from one
node to another we would like to find
the shortest path because why go long if
you can go short and what betweenness
centrality basically means in connect
intuitive way is that notes that are
more prominent in a belong to more
shortest path between any two nodes
these are more important nodes which
kind of intuitively make sense these are
the connectors or the influences of the
big kind of the strongest layer you know
people in the in the network because
everything goes with them and you know
network X obviously has some try to
measure so you need to call network X
centrality betweenness centrality you
get scores for each node and then if we
kind of go back and just you know plug
darts call this corset which is
calculated into Network X then we can
visualize it they're going to take a
second run and you can see that you know
take Turlington and Lincoln over here
your use todd are more interestingly or
more important notes depending on their
between s and Shattuck so the larger the
know the more important that person is
and the interest of time I'm just gonna
kind of freeze do this and we're going
to do the same with paid the PageRank
algorithm and we can see that people
kind of in have in the center of the
network relatively more importance and
people on the side so just to tie it
back to our original questions that we
asked if I'm the customer service team
whose customer service code should we
answer first and the answer is one of
those important nodes in the middle
because if I look at just this guy this
can all Berto if I
him obviously as a company I would like
to give everyone good service but you
know there are constraints so if I have
to cause one is one of them is from you
know link on my money one is from
Alberto I would like to answer Lincoln's
call first and I would if I had only ten
pounds to even compensation I would like
to give you know link on all that ten
pounds probably because if Alberto
doesn't use the app anymore that's fine
because the only you know he only is
connected to one person the network so
the collateral damage of losing Alberto
is just losing one person but if I'm
losing
if I give link on a bad customer
experience and I'm losing him then all
of these connections will be severed so
I'm at risk of losing more individuals
and similarly you know the marketing
team wanted to know who the influences
are so we can see kind of from different
centrality measures who are the
influencers and likewise customer
research team wants to know who to
interview product team wants to know
like who are the best tester so who'd
should we keep in mind when we launching
or will this kind of thinking about new
features then those power users often
the kind of people you want to interview
because they would have interesting
insights in what make a the product kind
of be adopted by more and more people so
these are the people you need to keep in
mind now and I'm sorry I'm rushing
through things I do have a hard stop so
I just want to wrap up nicely and I'm
going to skip through these there is
your vision exam voting examiner you can
see the link right here I'll publish it
basically it looks at all of the
Eurovision votes along the years and see
is you know which companies give which
countries will give votes to which other
countries and you can see blocks you can
definitely blogs and I think you kind of
can kind of guess which what the blocks
look like yourselves because if you have
ever seen Eurovision Song Contest you
know that you know it's a rigged game
let's be honest in my opinion
cool so closing remarks okay we we
answered a real-world business question
using network analysis in just a few
minutes okay which is pretty cool we saw
that it's it's powerful it's widely
applicable would barely scratch the
surface so there is a whole lot to learn
and I encourage every one of you to go
and I will publish in coming days I will
publish a lot of reading material and
other sources you can read to go and
study it even more even read the
documentation on network X because
that's even another good way to kind of
familiarize yourself is more and more
things that have to do with network
analysis and yeah and Python is right so
I'll post a lot of next steps and and
and you know links if you should go to I
also kind of try to share the slides and
code in some manner I'm not sure exactly
how just yet but I'm kind of reach out
to know when I have the exact details so
you can follow me on Twitter and I'll
probably also post it there at some
point so with that I really thank you
for the opportunity I think it's really
really cool that we managed to talk with
the people in Indonesia and Buenos Aires
which is like could not have anticipated
that so thank you and with that I'm
gonna have to rush to into another call
so thank you very much everyone